Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir.
Vous avez peut-être vu l’image
du Pape en doudoune sur vos écrans.
Vous avez peut-être aussi vu
l’image d’Emmanuel Macron
qui ramasse les poubelles.
Vous avez peut-être aussi
entendu parler du faux duo
entre le rappeur Drake
et le chanteur The Weeknd,
c’est-à-dire en fait le duo
le clone vocal de Drake
et le clone vocal de The Weeknd.
Vous avez aussi entendu parler de ChatGPT,
mais est-ce que vous avez entendu parler
de l’intelligence artificielle
utilisée comme un instrument de musique,
un instrument de création ?
Peut-être pas.
Moi, je suis musicien en résidence
dans une équipe de recherche
dirigée par François Pachet,
qui est le pape de l’IA -
sans doudoune je pense.
Avec cette équipe,
mon rôle est de développer
des outils de création
pour les musiciens de demain.
Dès le début de mes expérimentations,
qui datent de 2015,
j’ai été séduit, parfois très inspiré
par les résultats que j’ai obtenus
avec la machine.
Alors j’en ai fait un projet artistique
qui s’appelle Skygge,
et Skygge en danois,
ça veut dire « l’ombre ».
L’ombre qui est aussi le titre
du conte d’Andersen, « L’Ombre ».
Évidemment,
je n’ai pas commencé la musique
en 2015 avec l’intelligence artificielle.
J'ai commencé la musique et à écrire des
chansons dans le milieu des années 90
avec le groupe Lilicub -
peut-être que vous connaissez.
Et après, j’ai écrit des chansons
pour pas mal d’interprètes
comme Imani, comme Françoise Hardy,
comme Michel Sardou
ou même Johnny Hallyday.
Ce qui m’intéresse en fait
depuis le début de mes expérimentations
et depuis le début de mes compositions
avec un piano
ou avec n’importe quel instrument,
c'est de me laisser surprendre
par ce que je fais.
C’est-à-dire qu’avec un piano,
laisser mes doigts décider pour moi
à un moment donné,
donc d’être dans une espèce d’état
de lâcher prise et de contrôle.
Et j’ai trouvé dans l’IA
un formidable partenaire
pour créer ces états
d’accidents contrôlés.
Je vais tout de suite vous faire écouter
un exemple à travers une chanson.
C’est une chanson de Pete Seeger,
qui a été enregistrée par ce chanteur
iconique de la folk américaine
des années 60.
Donc il l’a enregistrée en 1961.
Il était dans son studio
avec juste sa voix et son micro.
C’est-à-dire qu’il n’y avait
aucun accompagnement musical.
Je vous fais écouter cette chanson
qui est en fait
une chanson folk américaine
qui date du début du 20e siècle.
(Voix de Pete Seeger)
Black, black, black is the color
of my true love’s hair
Benoît Carré : Je ne vous fais pas
tout écouter, vous voyez l’esprit.
Pas d’accompagnement musical.
Et à ce moment-là, je développe,
avec les chercheurs,
un outil qui permet aux musiciens
de transférer,
d’adapter n’importe quelle orchestration
d’un morceau existant
sur n’importe quelle autre chanson.
Donc l’idée, là, c’est,
avec cette chanson,
j’étais très curieux de savoir
comment l’IA allait créer
un accompagnement
autour de cette voix que j’aime beaucoup -
c’est la voix de Pete Seeger -
et cette très belle chanson.
Donc il faut nourrir la machine
pour qu’elle produise quelque chose,
sinon c’est un système d’apprentissage
vide qui ne produit rien.
Moi, mon rôle, c’est d’essayer
de trouver une source musicale
qui soit intéressante, déjà,
d’un point de vue artistique.
Et comme cette mélodie est très simple,
je vais aller chercher
un style assez sophistiqué,
avec des harmonies très riches.
Et ce style, pour moi,
c’est la bossa nova.
Je ne sais pas si vous connaissez
la bossa nova, mais c’est un style musical
qui est apparu au Brésil, qui a été
inventé par Vinicius De Moraes,
par Joao Gilberto dans les années 60
et qui a la particularité d’avoir
des harmonies très riches, très belles.
Et comme on est dans les années 60,
il y a, par-dessus ces harmonies,
souvent des violons qui viennent se poser
et qui sont encore plus sophistiqués.
Le maître de ces arrangements
de violons, il s’appelle Claus Ogerman.
Peut-être que vous le connaissez.
Et je vais vous faire écouter
un extrait d’un arrangement
de violons de Claus Ogerman.
(Violons)
Vous entendez, ce sont
des harmonies très fines.
J’avais très envie de voir
comment l’IA allait se débrouiller,
avec ces harmonies-là,
sur cette chanson de Pete Seeger.
Mais je ne pouvais pas utiliser
cet arrangement
puisqu’il n’est pas libre de droit,
ça appartient à Claus Ogerman.
Donc j’ai demandé à un ami
qui est très doué pour imiter les styles,
et je lui ai demandé : « Écris-moi
un arrangement de violons
dans le style de Claus Ogerman
sur la chanson que tu veux. »
Alors pas Black is the Color
car celle-là, ça ne marcherait pas,
ce ne serait pas intéressant.
Donc il m’a écrit un arrangement
de violons que je vous fais écouter.
(Violons)
C'est un extrait.
Si je joue la chanson Black is the Color
sur cet extrait sans IA, ça donne ça.
(Voix de Pete Seeger)
Black, black, black is the color
Non, ce n’est pas terrible.
Ce que va faire l’IA,
c’est qu’elle va adapter automatiquement
l’arrangement qu’a fait mon ami,
de cordes,
et elle va faire en sorte de préserver
dans cet arrangement
ce qui est musical,
toutes les qualités musicales,
les changements de notes
et les mouvements internes.
Puis elle va l’adapter
à la chanson Black is the Color.
Voilà le résultat.
(Voix de Pete Seeger)
Black, black, black is the color
of my true love’s hair
I love the ground on which she stands
(Violons)
Vous entendez, à la fin,
le dernier accord, comme c’est beau !
Je vous le remets, je l’aime beaucoup.
(Voix de Pete Seeger)
the ground on which she stands
(Violons)
C’est magnifique !
Pour moi, quand je suis expérimentateur,
je quitte ma casquette d’expérimentateur
et je prends celle de musicien, d’artiste,
et je me dis :
« Il faut que je fasse quelque chose
avec cette chanson, c’est trop beau ! »
Donc j’appelle une autre amie qui, elle,
est chef d’orchestre,
qui est arrangeuse, et à qui je demande
d’adapter cet arrangement
fait par la machine
pour un orchestre, un petit orchestre,
un quatuor de quatre violons
qui sont des musiciens
du Philharmonique de Radio France.
Et donc elle a fait les partitions
et on est allés en studio
pour enregistrer la chanson.
(Voix de Pete Seeger)
Black, black, black is the color
of my true love’s hair
Her face is something wondrous fair
The purest eyes
and the daintiest hands
I love the ground
on which she stands
(Violons)
Là, c’est une belle histoire,
tout marche bien, c’est parfait.
Mais l’IA, comme je le disais
tout à l’heure, il faut la nourrir,
il faut lui donner une source musicale,
et comme j’ai
une infinité de possibilités,
je ne passe pas un temps infini sur l’IA,
mais je vais essayer d’autres choses
et ça ne marche pas toujours.
Je tenais ce soir à vous faire
écouter ce qui ne marche pas.
Quelques exemples ratés.
(Même chanson sur un tempo rapide)
Bon, ce n’est pas faux, mais ce n’est pas
artistiquement très intéressant.
Un autre exemple avec une autre chanson
qui s’appelle « Oh Shenandoah »,
chantée par Pete Seeger, le même.
Là, j’étais sûr que ça allait marcher.
Je vous laisse découvrir
la source musicale.
Peut-être que la reconnaîtrez,
pour ceux qui aiment la musique classique.
(Voix de Pete Seeger) Oh Shenandoah
I love your daughter
Away you rolling river
Vous ne reconnaissez pas ?
C’est le premier mouvement de
la Symphonie du Nouveau Monde de Dvorak.
J’étais sûr que ça allait marcher,
l’idée était belle.
De la folk, la Symphonie du Nouveau Monde…
Ce qui marche sur le papier
ne marche pas forcément dans la réalité.
Avec l'IA, c'est la même chose.
Là, ce qu’on a vu, c’est une
expérimentation sur un exemple,
en tout cas, sur la musique,
on va dire, plutôt symbolique, les notes.
Mais l’IA peut être aussi
très intéressante et créative
sur l’aspect du son,
c’est-à-dire l’expressivité.
Alors là aussi, avec l’équipe,
on a travaillé sur un outil
de sampling intelligent
qui permet de donner de l’expressivité
à une partition qui n’en a pas forcément.
Là, même chose, je commence
par donner à la machine une musique.
C’était un peu aléatoire, j’ai pris
ce que j’avais sous la main :
une fugue de Schubert.
Donc je vous joue la fugue de Schubert
que j’avais sous la main.
(Musique)
C'est un peu plat.
Ce n’est pas très expressif.
(Musique)
Voilà.
Je cherche un peu
ce qui pourrait donner
de l’expressivité à ce morceau-là.
Un piano, c’est un peu convenu.
Peut-être un instrument
un peu moins convenu.
Donc je suis allé sur internet
et puis je suis tombé sur…
(Vidéo)(Musique)
Vous ne connaissez peut-être pas
cet instrument, c’est une cuica.
Une cuica, c’est un instrument brésilien.
Ça a l’air facile à jouer,
mais je ne pense pas que ça le soit.
C’est un instrument brésilien utilisé
dans la samba,
dans les orchestres de samba.
Donc j’ai demandé à la machine :
« Machine, s’il te plaît,
fais en sorte que la cuica,
cette cuica, interprète la fugue. »
Je vais vous jouer un petit peu
de la fugue que je viens de vous jouer
pour vous rappeler.
Et ensuite, j’enchaînerai sur la cuica.
(Musique)
(Musique, changement d’instrument)
Très inattendu.
J’étais aussi surpris
que, peut-être, vous.
Et comme j’avais le…
C'est moi qui avait les commandes.
Je me suis dit qu’il fallait que je fasse
quelque chose avec cette chanson.
Ce n'était pas une chanson,
c'était juste un extrait.
Donc j’ai mis cet extrait en boucle puis
j’ai improvisé à la voix, j’ai cherché.
Et puis m’est venue une chanson,
qui s’appelle « Océan Noir »
et qui est sur mon album Melancholia
qui est sorti l’année dernière.
Plus récemment, vous avez entendu
peut-être parler du faux duo
entre Drake et The Weeknd ?
Ça a créé beaucoup de réactions
assez négatives
de la part des maisons de disques,
ce qui est compréhensible.
Les journalistes aussi.
Et tout le milieu de la musique.
C’est normal puisqu’on s’attaque
à la voix.
La voix, c’est ce qu’on écoute en premier
quand on écoute une chanson,
c’est ça qu’on entend.
Mais…
il y a une voix qui s’est fait entendre,
un peu différente,
c’est la voix de Grimes.
Je ne sais pas si vous connaissez Grimes.
C’est une chanteuse canadienne, pop,
qui chante en anglais.
Cette chanteuse a tweeté,
c’était vers la fin avril :
« Eh bien moi, j’ai un clone vocal
et je le mets à disposition des artistes.
Les artistes qui veulent faire
une chanson avec mon clone vocal,
partageons les revenus à 50 / 50. »
Moi, j’ai trouvé ça très bien.
Très bonne idée.
Et justement, j’ai repensé
à ma chanson « Océan Noir »
qui parle d’un espace
d’incommunicabilité, de déréliction.
Et je me suis dit :
« Si je remplaçais ma voix,
qui est ma voix physique,
par la voix de Grimes ? »
C’est-à-dire que c’est moi qui chante,
mais…
c’est le timbre de Grimes
qui remplace mon timbre.
Je vais vous faire écouter -
j’ai extrait ma voix de la chanson.
J'ai enlevé tous les instruments.
Je vais vous faire écouter
ma voix toute seule.
(Voix de Benoît Carré) Océan Noir
J’entends les baleines dans un acouphène.
Ici, aucune vague m’accoste.
Je donne ma voix à la technologie
qui s’appelle Health Tech
qui va prendre cette voix,
qui va garder le chant, les intonations,
mais qui va remplacer mon timbre
de voix par celui de Grimes.
(Voix de Grimes) Océan Noir
J’entends les baleines dans un acouphène
Ici, aucune vague n’accoste
Aucun souffle n’étoffe
Les voiles bleues des promesses vaines
Voilà, et la chanson sort
dans deux jours, le 23 juin donc.
Ça tombe bien.
Là, on voit la puissance de l’IA
quand les outils fonctionnent.
On voit à quel point
ça peut être disruptif,
à quel point ça peut bouleverser
à la fois les questions de droit,
parce que c’est le droit d’interprète, là,
les questions aussi de business
qui sont un peu bouleversées,
mais ça peut être aussi des opportunités.
Il ne faut pas qu’on s’y trompe non plus,
qu’on dise : « L’IA remplace les artistes
ou en tout cas remplace leur timbre. »
Parce que le timbre,
c’est un peu ce qu’il y a tout en haut
d’une chanson quand elle est terminée,
c’est le vernis, on peut dire.
Et avant, vous l’avez vu à travers
ces quelques exemples,
il y a beaucoup de travail,
il y a la composition,
il y a aussi l’arrangement,
puis il y a le son
et à chaque étape,
il faut créer des outils intéressants
pour les musiciens
qui, avec l’IA, leur permettent
d’explorer justement
des endroits où ils ne sont jamais allés
et peut-être les aider à créer davantage
ou au moins différemment.
Donc on est encore loin d’une IA
qui va générer une chanson de A à Z.
Mais la révolution est en marche,
ça, c’est sûr.
Il y a eu la révolution Internet
avec le peer to peer, avant le stream,
qui a détruit pas mal de musiciens.
Et puis il y a eu le stream justement
avec ces 0,00000, je ne sais pas combien,
0,02€ par clic.
Maintenant, il y a l'IA.
Je vous invite vous,
et tous ceux derrière leur écran,
à dépasser le fantasme
et à regarder ce qu’est l’IA aujourd’hui
pour que l’IA demain soit
plutôt notre amie qu’une menace.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)